my first guest
is the funniest comedian on the planet
his film dave chappelle's block party
will be available june 13th on dvd
please welcome dave chappelle
[Music]
[Music]
um
that's nice
all right
you know what i love is your reaction
your reaction to 4 000 people cheering
you is like oh yeah hi
i don't know what to do i forgot what
that was like
you've been away for a while yeah it was
it was quiet yeah
yeah there was some quiet time there we
got a lot to talk about here i haven't
seen you in
in a long time first of all what have
you been up to what's what's dave
chappelle been doing with himself
nothing nothing this guy's coming out
season three
good to see you
nice try comedy central yeah that's one
of their executives
we need the doe come on i've been
i've been really just relaxing and just
trying to stay out of trouble
right right that's right because i see
you know i mean you know
being a celebrity your realm of getting
in trouble
is is worse than the average person
you know i mean like the average dude
gotta go out and look for trouble
i'd be sitting around my own business
and dude come on hey man you're japan
i'm like yeah
what's up man hey i got 12 naked [ __ ]
in hot air balloon you trying to roll
call me next time all right i need to
get out of the house once in a while
that's why i just stay in the house yeah
it's it's funny because like when i come
out everybody screams
but when i go home it's not like that
when you go home i mean that's the thing
that's important to remember is that
when you go home it's a different
situation right
yeah my kids don't even care they're
like oh mr promise is back from the road
did you forget all them toys you
promised us mr promise
and then my wife's still a little salty
at me she's not happy with you right now
she's not mad at me but don't think
you're gonna walk away from
50 million dollars and your wife's just
going to be cool with it
[Applause]
that's an angle i hadn't thought about
yet it was crazy i thought i was going
to get the jerry maguire baby you can be
anything you want to be speech
yeah it didn't pan out no
it was more like purple rain around my
house
yeah i know what it sound like when the
birds cry now
okay i've known you for a long time
you've been coming on our show for a
long time i've bumped into you in the
street sometimes in new york
you're you're a very normal
down-to-earth guy you really do
seem like you're very unaffected by all
this do you think that's fair
i'm a little weird but i'm quirky yeah
but like
but yeah my life is pretty normal like
like i get
amazed by this too i was in l.a doing
the grammys you know i will i wear white
clothes i'm on tv and a t-shirt
now so i had to get some clothes for the
grammys so i went to one of these nice
beverly hills stores they had like
a restaurant in the store i never ate
soup
at a clothing store before but it was
real bowling
and i'm eating soup and i looked across
the room
and and i see jessica simpson so i'm
like oh
i'm like that's jessica simpson and i
was like oh wait a minute
i'm famous baby so
that's right you could yes i you could
go up and say something well
that's what i decide now i don't
normally do this but it was jessica
simmons i said let me just see
you know what's going on so i went up
i'm like uh hi jessica simpson
uh i don't know what to say i'm like my
name's dave chappelle i was like
i'm on tv too yeah
and she was like i know who you are and
i was like i knew it [ __ ]
i didn't say that to her
but i got excited i did i was i was i
was
you got excited yeah i was on corn i was
like well i'm a big fan of work which
felt weird saying you know
cause that's not true but uh
i'm not i'm not dogging her music i
don't know her music i'm talking about
the newlywed show you know
i've been a newlywed it's nothing like
that show
and i made a show about my first-year
marriage because [ __ ] tricked me
but but if you're a romantic fool yeah
no no i look i'm crazy about my wife
that's why i see these jokes about me
and my wife
well you stop shouting at me i'm talking
uh-huh but uh
but but okay all right thank you
yeah so what is the end of the story
yeah
but the crazy part is you know she was
real nice if you're a fan of hers you'll
be happy to know
she was great and uh when i sat back
down as a matter of fact i was
finishing my soup up and she was leaving
this was crazy she came up to me that
she was leaving she was like bye-bye
chappelle's nice to meet you
and she she gave me some some sugar
she gave you a kiss yeah which was crazy
because i opened my mouth a little bit i
had
yeah you did what you had to do
let's get into this now uh because
everyone wants to
to hear what's been going on you uh you
disappeared for a while
people people were saying where's dave
where's dave chappelle where's he going
and then uh it turns out you took a trip
to africa is that true
yeah it's true yeah it wasn't like they
said
right it was the stories were i mean the
stories as you know you're hearing all
kinds of stuff on the news
it was crazy man i i mean first i went
to africa to chill
and i tell you hear a lot of black
people say this
like when you go to africa especially
your first time you have this
overwhelming feeling like your home
which is true i've i had to feel like
man this feels like home
i think i felt that way because there's
a mcdonald's in the airport
so i got my big mac but then it was like
it got it just got out of control like i
was in africa and
next time i started hearing all the
stories like comedian dave chappelle was
in a
mental institution in south africa and i
was like man i must be
losing my mind yeah because i thought
this was the beach
yeah and everybody calls me craig you
know i mean
you're hearing on the news things like
he's gone crazy which uh never sounded
that doesn't sound right
you know you know maybe i know stuff
people don't want me to talk about so
like
oh other people believe so they'll call
me crazy
but it was a weird thing to get called
crazy at first it was scary
and then now i feel like it's liberating
like
i feel free like i can just say what i
want to do i want they already call me
crazy
i can't hold myself accountable for
these things i'm crazy
yeah i hate my fault yeah
i couldn't control myself yeah yeah what
was
was there was there i mean uh what was
the reason that you went to africa
was there a reason that you decided to
go to africa well there are a few
reasons but
i mean you know if you're a black dude
trying to hide africa is a good place
it's a
you know blackheads pick my profile yeah
i was like i'm going to go to ireland
it was i had man i had a good time and
another thing i loved about africa was
the people
you know it was so warm and and like i
was i was talking to them about my
problems and they listen like they don't
know nothing about chappelle show
they just listen and i be like man you
know i had this show and i felt like
people was trying to control me i was
freaked out
i don't know i just had to get out of
there walked away it says 5th mcdonald's
it's all gone i'm scared and i was
and they was hey hey they did all this
to you brother i said that's how i be
doing in america
that's messed up man they said but here
in africa
we have a philosophy that helps us get
through things like this you've always
got to remember one thing
when you go through these problems dave
and i said what's that brother
and he said i ate a dog today
just grow up get older yeah get over
yourself
you don't want 50 million dollars boo
hoo yeah yeah get get over yourself yeah
yeah
it happens man you know but but it was a
it was definitely
a what you call it a growing experience
that's for sure
you know and it does feel like it's
liberated you not to get too heavy but
it does feel like this whole thing has
freed you up a little bit you know
excuse me one second
[Music]
that'll be the clip they use on the news
we were right he's gone crazy uh
i'm going to mention this dave
chappelle's block party uh by michelle
gandrea
this is great this is coming out on
dvd and it's going to be uh available
on june 13th and i got to tell you um
it is a it is a real pleasure just i
mean i say this all the time in the show
i say it's a real pleasure to have you
come on the program
but i wrote you a little note and
everybody wants to talk to dave
chappelle i wrote you a little note
and you responded and said i'll be there
and it was incredibly nice
you know we were very happy to have you
like the guy we wanted to have so yeah
it's
it's my pleasure and i didn't realize
this when i said yes but do you know
that tonight i think is my 22nd time on
the show
22nd time i've done your show more than
chappelle show i think
well thanks for having me man it's
always a rare pleasure
man dave chappelle commons coming up to
take a break we'll be right back